welcome to the
uh brain initiative trainee travel
awardee presentations where we're here
the first 15 or 30 uh awardees
these were selected from the abstract so
i'm here together with
uh michelle jones thunder from nids i
forgot to say i'm john nye director of
the brain initiative
i know these are very difficult times
for all of us i think we've
managed to capture a lot of the
scientific content and to
maintain momentum going forward and i'm
particularly delighted to
be here together with michelle to listen
to some great talks by our trainees who
will be leading the future charge of the
brain initiative and beyond
once they're done with their training so
with that
i'm about to turn it over to the to the
talks
um you'll see in the question and answer
box you can ask questions
of the uh presenters as you go along in
your real time uh when you do so please
make sure to
note who you're directing the question
to so michelle and i can help
direct traffic and then at the end of
the presentations
we will be reading the questions and be
asking the presenters
to answer and get into the discussion
so with that i'm going to let them take
it away with the presentations and we'll
check back in at the end in about 30
minutes
and hopefully have a great discussion
from all the attendees
thanks very much
hello my name is blake caldwell and i'm
a postdoctoral researcher at brown
university in the lab dr
stephanie jones i'm going to talk about
a feature that we've added to our
software enabling efficient parameter
estimation for event related potential
simulations
the human neocortical neural solver h n
for short
is a software program that provides an
easy to use graphical user interface for
modeling the detailed biophysics and
economical cortical column that drive
exocranial meg and eeg signals
shown here are two types of exogenous
inputs with layer specific projection
patterns modeled in
h m when combined in sequences the
effect of these inputs on the network
produce the current dipole waveform at
the bottom
this output of the model is
representative of observed
mg or eeg signals a challenge to the
interactive use of the software is the
time it takes to run each of these
complex simulations
in the case of parameter estimation
where input timing and synaptic
strength must be tuned for each input
existing approaches let all parameters
vary in a high dimensional optimization
problem
this quickly becomes impractical on a
laptop
users may bring in their own data and
want to use h m to assist
in developing hypotheses about
differences at the micro circuit level
that account for signal changes in a
disease state
versus healthy controls in order to make
this efficient
enough to run on a laptop we leverage
the fact that exogenous inputs to the
network exert time dependent effects
we take this into account when computing
a weighted goodness of fit metric
in this way an optimal fit is found for
each input's parameters
before moving on to the next input
allowing the entire optimization to
complete after fewer total simulations
we have made this feature available in
the current release of the h
and software available at h n.brown.edu
for users to begin investigating the
neural origin of their erp data
we would welcome feedback and
contributions as we grow our open source
community
thanks for listening
hello everyone today i'm going to
present material engineering tools
for precise intervention and monitoring
neural activity
to better understand the neural circular
mechanism and develop effective
treatments
for neurological disorders it is
essential to discover the causal link
between behavior output and cellular
activity
material engineering approaches can
provide
methodological assistance to establish
tools
for precise intervention and monitoring
your activity
with simultaneous behavior output here
we present precise intervention tools
for remotely controlled neural
modulation
and real-time recording techniques to
monitor neuron dynamics
we first establish a magnetic toolkit
for remote neural modulation
which allows remotely controlled release
of pharmacological compounds
to modulate targeted neural circuits
we applied custom developed alternating
magnetic field apparatuses
to wirelessly deliver magnetothermal
stimuli
into deep brain structures such as
ventral tegmental area and nucleus
compass
in freely moving mice with multiple
behaviors
for simultaneous monitoring neural
activity
we invented soft and stretchable optical
fibers
to monitor neurodynamics from multiple
sites
across central nervous system in fully
behaving mice
with simultaneous behavior output
equipped with genetically encoded
fluorescence probes
this kind of stretchable and flexible
optical devices
enabled real-time results of
neurodynamics
with high cell type specificity and
overcome
in vivo working condition limits of the
conventional stiff silica based optics
which will result in recording failure
if vigorous locomotion is involved
hello i am dr daryl narcisse a research
scientist at nanoscope technologies in
bedford texas
at nanoscope our research primarily
focuses on applying
optogenetics to neurological challenges
for both research
and clinical applications as a part of
our research efforts
we developed vmc02 a membrane-bound
construct with both actuator and sensor
domains to allow direct stimulation of
cells
at light levels as low as 10 microwatts
per square millimeter
and rapid bioluminescence reporting of
cellular activity
in this study we used the sensor domain
of bmco2
and transfected neurons to perform
long-term neurological activity imaging
in response to visual stimulation in a
cell-specific manner
without the phototoxic and
photobleaching effects often seen in
fluorescence-based imaging
the actuator domain has been used in
other studies to resensitize
remaining retinal cells into generated
retinas
the bmc02 construct allows safe and
accurate monitoring of biological
activity
which will prove useful in understanding
the neurological activity underlying
processing
in the central nervous system as you see
in the figure
this study shows the use of bnc02 for 14
consecutive hours
and showed a spike in neurological
activity in the visual cortex related to
the natural circadian rhythm
of our murian model when quantified
there was a measurable increase between
seven and eight hours
and the number of active neurons the
intensity of the fractional change in
bioluminescence
activity and the fidelity of responses
in executive visual stimulations
we continue to push the boundaries of
bmc02 by using it to monitor the disease
progression via the changes in visually
evoked cortical activity
over several weeks in rd10 mice as a
model of retinal degeneration
is our hope to use the sensor and
actuator functions of emc02
to gain a greater understanding of the
activity in the visual cortex and
directly stimulate the visual cortex to
restore siding conditions wherein the
normal input from the retina is
compromised
for example optic nerve damage or
nucleation of the eye
hi my name is nicole provenza i am a phd
candidate in the borton lab at brown
university
my work focuses on finding neural
markers of symptom states related to
obsessive compulsive disorder or ocd to
enable adaptive deep brain stimulation
for ocd
deep brain stimulation or dbs in the
ventral capsule of ventral striatum
or vcbs for short improves symptoms in
about 50 to 70 percent of otherwise
treatment resistant patients
titrating dbs to respond to symptoms as
they arise may be a more effective
approach for treating symptoms and
reducing side effects of stimulation
with this approach neural signals would
be used to classify symptoms state
and stimulation parameters would
automatically be adjusted
however this requires neural markers and
symptom state which are currently not
well defined
here i am showing bcvs delta band power
from 0.1 to 4 hertz
and one participant with ocd over 20
weeks after dbs was turned on
every few weeks the participant comes
into the clinic for dbs programming
local field potentials are recorded at
rest immediately before and after
programming
after dbs was turned on for the first
time at week zero we did not observe a
difference in delta band power
however over the following eight weeks
we observed an upward trend in delta
band power
that was not found to be associated with
changes in dbs amplitude
or impedance of sensing contacts at week
16
a different dbs contact was chosen
during programming
this change shifted the location in
simulation and sensing contacts 3
millimeters downward
and at week 16 the upward trend in the
delta van power
went away it is our hypothesis that bcbs
delta band power
may be a neural marker of the initial
mood and energy
improvements typically observed in dbs
for ocd
ultimately i hope to find a neural
marker of ocd symptom state to enable
adaptive dbs and improve the efficacy
of dbs for treatment resistant ocd
afternoon everyone i am stephanie
costanzo a phd candidate in the golden
globe at the sulkey institute
our united aim is to characterize spinal
circuits for the control of dexterous
movements
neural circuits in the cervical spinal
cord participate to a range of
fundamental behaviors
including locomotion and skill breaching
even if we have genetic access to major
classes of pre-motor interneurons
we have limited knowledge on how they
are organized to drive functional
behavior
to fill in this gap we decided to create
a high definition spinal cord atlas
focusing on mapping the spatial
distribution of
four major classes of spinal cord
interneurons
in relation to six specific cervical
motor neuron pools
i contributed to this work together with
queen silverman
by generating a high definition special
map of spinal cord
ventral interneurons in particular v1
and b2 enter neurons as you can see
in the short video on the right
here we are generating a
three-dimensional rendering
of the cervical spinal cord using
software platforms called
build a brain generated by jeff moore
here at the salky institute and brain
maker
from mbf in this model ingredient
represented the genetically labeled b1
neurons
and in red the triceps motor neurons
regulatedly labeled with ctb
and used as an anatomical landmark our
main goal is to use these datasets to
create an expandable
reference atlas they will allow
integration of molecular and
connectivity data
to other spinal cell types sensory
operands
and descending motor pathways that will
be used to build predictive models of
motor function hello
i'm edward zokan i'm a phd candidate
studying electrical and computer
engineering at cornell university
my research interest is an integrated
circuit design for radio and biological
applications
neural prostheses have been effective in
treating neurological disorders using
electrical stimulation through
microelectrodes
however the long-term viability of
electrical stimulation has been limited
due to glial scarring encapsulation
degrading electric field strengths over
time
furthermore microelectro
neurostimulation suffers from the
inability to selectively activate
neurons based on the cell's orientation
microcoil based magnetic stimulation
overcomes both of these obstacles since
the magnetic fields have a high
permeability to biological tissue and
the induced electric fields are
spatially asymmetric
while recent improvements in
nanofabrication technology have allowed
for the creation of implantable
microcoil devices
the devices lack reconfigurable hardware
leading to fixed stimulation sites post
insertion
the proposed neural probe utilizes cmos
technology to integrate programmable
current drivers into individual micro
coils allowing for spatially
programmable neurostimulation sites
the neural probe has two input currents
that are passed along to an array of
programmable current
amplifiers designed with binary weighted
current mirrors
the output currents are further
amplified by the coil drivers which use
a push-pull
amplifier topology operating in class a
b to trade off between static power
consumption
and maximum output current drive to make
the neural probe the circuitry is
released from the original packaging
using standard photolithography
techniques as well as a series of plasma
etching and wet etching steps
the release neural probe is mounted to a
carrier circuit board and encapsulated
in perylene
preliminary in vitro testing with mouse
retinal tissue and patch clamp
measurements have been promising
but future lab work needs to be done
with a multi-electrode array to
characterize the programmable
stimulation site
while this style of neural probe can be
used to innovate new technology for
neural prostheses
it also introduces a new method of
neurostimulation to the circuit
community
creating a new design space for circuit
designers working on neural interfaces
hello i'm erin tuttle from northeastern
university
and today i'm going to give an overview
of my graduate research on
quantitative mapping of ph using mri
mri is particularly well suited for
brain imaging as it is non-invasive and
can permeate the skull and layers of
tissue
without affecting image quality however
traditional contrast enhanced mri is a
qualitative technique
which limits the application of mri as
we try and better understand the human
brain
our goal is to develop a nanosensor and
image analysis platform
for quantitative mapping of biomolecules
to overcome the current limitation
in this work we validate the
quantitative mapping technology
by measuring ph our approach uses a ph
responsive nanosensor comprised of two
contrast agents with a nitrophenyl arm
that will protonate at lower ph and
cause an increase in relaxivity
the two contrast agents differ in the
metal center present
and are incorporated into a 100
nanometer liposome in a two to one ratio
of dysprosium to gadolinium
as seen in part a of the figure this
composition was chosen to have distinct
changes
in both t1 and t2 sensor response is
analyzed with dual contrast
resonance fingerprinting a technique
developed by our collaborator chris
flask
by rapidly measuring both t1 and t2 of a
sample
an image analysis equation can be
constructed from standards
that relates the change in those
parameters to ph
the results of a blinded test are shown
in part b of the figure
where the combined sensor and dc mrf
platform was used to calculate the ph
of unknowns within .05 ph units
this approach can detect and
unambiguously quantify ph
as shown in the present work and has the
ability to be applied to any analyte of
interest in the future
for non-invasive dynamic mapping of
biomolecules
using mri
hello i'm olivia de misguita tacita and
i am a phd student at arizona state
university
working with dr sridhaham and doctrine
to swami to develop a novel mutation
array for simultaneous monitoring of
local brain oxygen tension
and multi-unit activity we know that
oxygen plays a role in the regulation of
neural function
however its gradients in the immediate
vicinity of chronic invasivener
interfaces are naughty
at no i am very excited to work in this
project
because i think this microelectrode
array will help us to better understand
the critical role
of oxygen dynamics in the function of
chronic nerve interfaces
used for narrow monitoring and
neuromodulation
in this poster session i'll be
presenting our advances in null
fabrication techniques
needed for molding soft materials and
for the first time
report both oxygenation levels in local
brain tissue
and multi-unit activity using the same
neural interface that is readily
translatable to the clinic
brain connectomes are widely used in
neuroscience
however visualizing them can be very
difficult
due to large number of edges that you
may have in the matrix
for example if you do have 268 nodes
in the atlas you will end up with 35k
possible edges as part of bsfip project
we developed a connectivity viewer panel
that shows you three different layers of
visualization
in age level we show you a circle plot
of both positive and negative edges
and in the node level you will see a
surface plot
finally in network level we provided a
chord plot
and also a summary matrix that shows you
the correlation of the different brain
networks with each other
we provided three different human
athletes including chain 268
shin 368 and al and
one more animal atlas for mice
all this panel is developed in
javascript
so you don't need to install any single
package or library
all you need is to go to biscuit project
and under connectivity to your panel
upload your connector you can export
all these figures alongside each other
for your paper
hi my name is keith behrmann and i am a
phd candidate with the electrical
engineering department at columbia
university under professor john kimesis
this is a collaborative project
involving the 3d fast volumetric imaging
microscope
with our colleagues at university of
colorado anschutz and university of
colorado boulder
we are radically miniaturizing imaging
components for in-vivo head-mounted
microscopes
we aim to facilitate uninhibited
movement and behavior in mice to measure
neural activity
to do this we have developed a micro led
display with individually addressable
pixels for use as a light source in
neural imaging and modulation
the high resolution display small pixel
size fine pitching custom micro lens
array integrated into the 3d fast
microscope
enable enables 3d volumetric imaging and
stimulation over 1.5 millimeters squared
field of view with 150 microns of axial
scanning depth
this enables us to record and modulate
over 23 000 neurons
the display is attached to a 70
centimeter long cable
flexible pcb that is lightweight and
insensitive to bending
allowing free movement by the mice
without the complications that come with
bent
fiber-based display systems with the
micro led array as an imaging source we
aim to capture high resolution
volumetric images of neural activity
obtaining this level of fidelity and
circuit observation and manipulation can
give insight into critical brain
functions
including those that underlie behavior
cognition learning and memory
hello everyone my name is father
karnishin and i am a graduate student
in the rehab neural engineering labs at
the university of pittsburgh
our research focuses on the neuroscience
and functional utility
of bi-directional brain computer
interfaces
a promising intervention could hardly
restore independence
to people living with tesseraction by
bypassing the damaged spinal cord
using devices implanted directly into
the cortex
these bi-directional bcis could
potentially replace
motor functions by decoding patterns of
neural activity
in the motor cortex associated with
motor intent
to move across seizures and they could
also restore glass
of sensory functions by electrically
simulating relevant areas of the
somatosensory cortex
to generate consciously perceptile
sensations
so in this study we evaluated the
relative effects
of both visual and tactile feedback
through cortical microsimulation using
two types of control
computer and bci control on an object
compliance task our participant
was a 32 year old male with tetraplegia
and he was implanted with two utah
microelectrode aries
in the hand region of motor cortex and
two areas in area one
of the summer sensory cortex our results
have shown
that visual stimulation visual
and stimulation feedback alone resulted
in
him correctly identifying the objects
about 50
of the time however when both
types of feedback were available this
important
his performance increase is 70 and was
indistinguishable with predictions made
from optimal sensory integration
during active pci control by hand this
performance was poorer
than computer control this was likely as
a result
of the variable simulation feedback he
would receive
nevertheless the visual and similar
sensory cues
still combined in a way that was
consistent with optimal integration
predictions
these findings help us assess the
performance impact of sensory feedback
in bi-directional bcis and suggests that
this type of feedback
can be integrated naturally into motor
plants
motor control plans without training
hello there i'm general novak i'm a
graduate assistant studying sociology at
michigan state
our research team studies stakeholder
perceptions of select psychiatric
electrostatical interventions to
depression
namely electroconvulsive therapy
transcranial magnetic stimulation
deep brain stimulation and adaptive
brain implant
the stakeholder groups that we study are
psychiatrists
patients living with depression and
members of the public
today i will be discussing stakeholder
perceptions of the risks side effects
and benefits of the aforementioned
interventions
there has been a great deal of research
about the perceptions of stakeholders
relating to ect
this is because one ect has been around
for a long time
two ect is considered by many
psychiatrists to be effective treatment
for depression
and three ect has been shown in a
variety of media forums
usually in negative portrayals however
research about the perceptions of the
other interventions
well that's very sparse therefore we
conducted a total of 48 semi-structured
interviews with stakeholder groups
that i mentioned earlier we asked each
of them about one to two of the
interventions that we study in our
project
short-term memory loss resulting from
ect was the most mentioned benefit
excuse me most mentioned side effects
across all stakeholder groups
several patients suggested that
permanent damage was a possibility with
ect
but some also with tms and dbs also
some patients were concerned with having
a foreign body implanted in the brain
and that's associated with dbs there
were respondents who perceived of
effectiveness and quick response as
benefits of ect
but also with dbs and tms psychiatrists
in particular espouse the effectiveness
and patient's response time for ect
there were also patients and members of
the public who appeared optimistic
when talking about tms and dbs because
they could alleviate potentially the
need for a daily pill or medication
and this is why we do our research and
this is why we pursue
perceptions of stakeholders in response
to these interventions
hi everyone this is rachel garner and
i'm a project assistant at the
laboratory of neuroimaging at the
university of southern california
today i'll be sharing an update on
progress regarding the data archive for
the brain initiative
or daby which is a centralized archive
for human invasive
neurophysiology data specifically i'll
be elaborating on some of the methods
we're employing to address a central
challenge to data sharing in the field
of invasive neurophysiology
and that is data heterogeneity so most
partners have sent us data via ibm's
aspara
which is an encrypted hipaa compliant
high-speed file transfer system
aspara really minimizes the burden of
data sharing on investigators
by allowing them to upload data in their
local storage structures
we found that while some partners have
adopted standard specifications such as
brain imaging data structure
or neurodata without borders the
majority of partners collect
store and transfer data as unstructured
non-standard matlab variables or json
objects
we cannot automatically ingest and
harmonize these non-standard variables
as field names are inconsistent and data
must be reviewed manually
often alongside the provider themselves
before a comprehensive understanding of
the data is reached
so after parsing existing data sets and
consulting with davi partners
a database compatible json structure was
created to harmonize common metadata
fields
we've worked towards programming custom
parser pipelines for each project
allowing for ingestion of the
unstructured data into the harmonize
format
from there users can easily build
cohorts from harmonized variables within
dabi
shown in green in the figure our
ultimate goal with these harmonization
efforts is to reduce dataset
heterogeneity
while still minimizing investigator
burden following harmonization
multi-site studies will be made
available for query and cohort creation
allowing for increased statistical power
and evaluations of device safety and
implant efficacy
including identifying candidate patients
target brain regions
and recording and stimulation parameters
across sites
thanks so much for listening hi
my name is martin luszczynski i'm a
postdoc working at columbia university
i use electrophysiology across different
scales of neural organization
to understand mechanisms of cognition
when we study cognition we often do so
by asking participants to hold their
eyes still
while the experimenter is presenting
bits of information right in front of
their eyes
while this approach has been very
fruitful it misses important aspects of
natural vision
in natural vision we actively explore
our surroundings
it is our intention intentions goals and
interests that largely determine
what will fixate next and importantly at
which points in time will fixate it
in my work i combine intracranial
recordings in human epilepsy patients
with simultaneous eye tracking during
natural reviewing
this allows me to explore the influence
of eye movements on a distributed
network
and study both local neural processing
patterns and global network interactions
together with my colleagues at nathan
klein institute in new york we also
conduct similar experiments in non-human
primates
which allows us developing explanations
that bridge between species
a typical experiment might require
participants to look at a set of images
you see one example here or we might
give them a simple task
like to memorize the details of an image
or simply to ask whether they like an
image or not
by measuring simultaneously eye tracking
and neural activity
we can detect points of fixations and
eye movements and use them to sort the
neural data
you can see an example fill potentials
with fixation points
superimposed in the upper right panel
and fixation related phase coherence
in the lower left panel both images show
that fixations occur at a very specific
time points in relation to the field
potential
in the current work i am presenting at
this meeting i used such an approach to
evaluate the possibility that
circades influence large-scale neural
dynamics and operate beyond the visual
system
to our surprise we found that eye
movements impact indeed extends way
beyond the visual system to sub-critical
structures like non-visual thalamus
or even classical auditory critical
areas
you can see more details on my posterior
tta13
altogether this outlines a very exciting
theoretical proposition
that the eye movements structure not
only visual but also other sensory
perception like the auditory perception
i hope that by studying human brain in
the context of natural continuous and
active sampling behavior
we could develop a more comprehensive
understanding of both
brain and cognition
hi i'm christine a graduate student from
the clark lab at northeastern university
today i'll be talking about dna based
nanosensors for magnetic resonance
imaging
of acetylcholine in the brain the
project goal is to develop
nanostructured sensors
in this case mri contrast agents for
detecting
and in vivo monitoring of
neurotransmitters in the brain
imaging tools that enable real-time
visualization of molecular neural events
are valuable for understanding the basis
of brain function and disease
current methods such as
electrophysiology that utilizes
microelectrodes and optical imaging
have the ability to record neural
activity in the brain with relatively
high specificity and accuracy
however there can be added benefits to
this brain imaging toolbox
such as better spatial resolution and
monitoring chemical signals at a higher
scale
in this work we have developed an
acetylcholine responsive
mri nano sensor as shown in the sensor
design
we have a dna scaffold approximately 20
nanometers
with bi-sites for attaching the ph
sensitive gadolinium contrast agent
and acetylcholine catalyzing enzymes
the acetylcholine catalyzing enzymes
here butyl chlorine esterase
causes a local decrease in the ph by
hydrolyzing the acetylcholine into
acetic acid
which is then detected by the ph
sensitive contrast agent in close
proximity
leading to a measurable change in the
relaxation rate
ultimately giving off a stronger signal
intensity in the presence of
acetylcholine
dna based ph sensitive and acetylcholine
responsive
magnetic resonance nanosensors were
successfully prepared and shown to be
sensitive at various ranges of
acetylcholine concentration
this sensor provides a non-invasive
method for monitoring acetylcholine
and helps advance our understanding of
molecular neural signaling in the brain
thank you
hi so i think we're back live now um so
we have some questions a few questions
coming in
and i would like to ask the audience if
you have questions please feel free to
enter them in the question and answer
box and we will get to them in turn
the first question is for aaron and the
question has to do
the question has to do with the
accuracy and the range of sensitivity of
your ph based sensor
aaron are you on yes thank you for your
question
from the blinded test i showed in the
figure on my slide
we were able to calculate ph uh within
.05
ph units of the actual ph
which was measured by a second
researcher using a ph electrode
and i do believe that it's quite
accurate
if you consider the
range
we're looking at ranges that are
measured from
the physiological ph and sort of going
down closer to three or four because
that is where
the range for protonation deprotonation
of our sensor occurs
great okay thank you and and a follow
one question for that
is your calibration measurements uh
these were done
um in vitro or actual actual uh
biological tissue
so far the calibration measurements that
we use to create
the image analysis analysis equations
and that standard curve
are done in vitro using a relaxometer
so we can get very careful ph
measurements
of those samples and have the best
standard curve possible
terrific thank you very much
let's see the next question go ahead
michelle please
oh go ahead um our next question was a
follow-up to the bis
web and is there a tutorial that people
can use
thanks for the question yes we have
under each panel we
have a help menu and if you click on
that we provided a brief manual on how
to use
the corresponding uh panel
including connectivity viewer and we
have also youtube channel
that you can follow all those videos
and how to use biscuit
thank you thank you so much for that
question
okay this next question is for nicole um
are you seeing a similar trend in delta
band power for the other participants
with ocd
hi yes thank you for the question um we
have looked at one other participant so
far who's been in the study for a
shorter period
of time and so far we've observed an
increase in delta van power
over six weeks in the left vcbs for this
participant
but not the right ucvs and in the future
we plan to do electrolocalization to
figure out if electro placement might
explain this difference
thank you nicole morrison the next
question is for you
do you know the laminar origin of the
beta signal that you discussed
uh yeah so when human we don't you know
we usually record the
uh with the laminar resolution but um
based on previous
uh um monkey physiology i would expect
that to be primarily
in the superficial layers
all right thank you thank you this
question is for christine
the brain also changes ph locally how do
you distinguish ph sensitive
versus acetylcholine sensitivity with
your
sensor
hi um that is something
that i haven't considered thus far in my
research and um
i will make sure to look into that more
okay thank you for the answer though
um livia what is the chemical basis of
your oxygen
sensor and as a follow-up how is that
then incorporated into the probe
uh i just want to make sure it
understood the question is regarding to
the oxygen sensing
yes the oxygen sensor okay so
um how it works so i caught the
microelectrodes with polymer
siloxane which is the soluble matrix and
these are the mysteries of
sorry matrix called the suloxin sensor
which is a siloxane we have two
different forms uh
we use raw molecular weight padmeter
suloxane
and now we use tetradeca meteoroxane and
how works that we use
a mri technique called pistol
and we detect the changes of the spin
relaxation rate
and we correlate this with the oxygen
partial pressure of the
environment
and did you answer the second part
how it how is it exactly incorporated
into the pose
oh okay so what we do uh we
emerge the microelectrodes in the
siloxane sensor
over time so then the matrix uptakes the
sensor
okay thank you
great thanks so much uh this question is
for edward i believe
um regarding the probes can you say
anything about the dimensions of the
probes and you know what you think the
actual limits will be
uh yes that's an excellent question the
probes
in length are on the order of two
millimeters
uh and some designs are as long as maybe
three or four millimeters
the width of the probe is about 100
microns
and the thickness of the probes is
ranging from 100 to 75 microns
the main limitations as far as the width
goes
is uh because you have current flowing
in opposite directions producing the
magnetic fields
if they start getting too narrow the
magnetic fields will start
uh canceling each other out and then the
thickness itself is more of a structural
limitation the probe may just break on
insertion
great thanks so much it's very useful
information
um next question is for gerald a very
interesting
study did you can you comment a bit on
the extent to which
the responses you would get to your
general questions might
um to the extent you might see a
confluence or disparities between the
different groups that you might query
with the same questions and
and how might you quantitate those uh
similarities and differences
hi there well we um performed uh 48
interviews
uh with michigan based members of our
sample they were divided
equally among three stakeholder groups
so we had 16 psychiatrists 16 patients
and 16 members of the general public
and what we found was that psychiatrists
were very very um
likely to to promote the efficacy
and and will and the quick response of
ect
it was something that we found was was
pretty common among psychiatrists
we um were surprised though that uh
though dbs has not been uh clinically
established as
an effective treatment for depression
which is mainly what we're looking at
that there were and avia an adaptive
brain plant for that
for that matter that members of the
public and uh were very um
eager and interested in the in the
potential uh
for this for this intervention uh which
is one of the main reasons we're doing
our research is if there are disparities
between
what is you know clinically shown and
how stakeholders perceive
of these interventions we're going to
want to facilitate a more
accurate conveyance of information
great thank you very much uh next
question is for stefania
um with regard to your atlasing project
uh
what what's a realistic number of driver
lines that you think
you can um analyze and archive
and what's what's the throughput of your
of your pipeline right now
uh let me make sure i understood your
question so
how many months realistically it's going
to take to
uh go through different um samples and
genotypes is that the
question how many more yeah generally
yeah i mean just generally you know how
labor intensive is it and
how how large are the data sets and you
know how he's used it to navigate
around that at the moment of prince
philip
my technician is uh working around the
clock
on this and so essentially in terms of
the pipeline
he takes probably um
one week to process the tissue and
to get his images the image more or less
and consider the age of the animals
and when they are processed because you
process them as adult
animals uh let's say everything together
uh probably two to three months
just for imaging and compiling the data
analysis
and then for
data for further data analysis we are
going to send
our samples to a
company to outsource the analysis
but uh you know we are planning to um
apply the pipeline to different mouse
genotypes
and at the moment we have a little bit
of backlog
caused by the coronavirus so for me it's
a little bit um unrealistically i can't
really
for see how long it's going to take at
the moment but normally i would say
that for
i was we were pretty fast until now
let's say in
three months we have uh gone through at
least an n of three for two different
genotypes
uh two genotypes
great thanks and hopefully you and
everybody else will soon be able to get
back to work
and do so safely um the next question
uh yes the next question uh
it was not tagged to a specific speaker
but maybe a few of you
maybe a few of you folks can have
experience with this so just jump in
one at a time if you will the question
is as follows
with recording modulate recording and
modulating technologies
are you or how are you thinking about
synchronization with other data streams
such as behavioral recordings so how are
you
you know being able to sync up data from
different modalities
uh hi this is nicole provenza i can take
a stab at that first
so with the study i'm working on we are
doing dbs and human participants and we
also do
eeg at the same time as the local field
potential
recordings from the implanted electrodes
and the way we synchronize eeg with our
implanted recording
is by um toggling stimulation on and off
at a low frequency rate
um so the simulation
the change in simulation is visible both
on the eeg and the implanted recording
does anyone know yeah this is martinez
so
we're using simultaneous intracranial eg
and eye tracking so what we
uh usually do is like send every few
seconds uh
simultaneous time stamps or take time
stamps from
both devices so the eye tracker and
intracranial eg recording device
and then um this helps us to reassure
that we have
synchronized data streams and then use
the eye tracking for example you know
depending on the question
we might use the eye tracking to key our
neural signals so to find time points
of interest in the neural signal so
that's how we how we
deal with the problem okay
great this next question is for daryl
what is the low intensity light source
you're using
and and exactly how is it being
localized
all right thanks for the question it's
actually a uh led
light that we have just kind of
positioned uh we
measure out about five millimeters from
the eye
and we're using that as just for direct
visual stimulation or
a similar step when we're doing the in
vitro studies where we just
point an actual led and keep it
synchronized with our
electrical recordings but we point it at
the actual
cortical slice
thank you thanks thanks very much
another question for christine
um in in using ph as a sensor for
neurotransmitters through this very
elegant chemistry can you think
or are you planning on looking at other
neurotransmitters that might take
advantage of this this unique chemistry
are there other probes that you're
thinking of developing
um currently for this work uh there's
we're i'm focusing on
acetylcholine but there have been other
neurotransmitter of interest
um some
some other examples that people can
potentially use us for and
have studied are dopamine
and there's also different types of
probes such as a tyrosinase probe
so there are others that do exist and it
could definitely expand to other probes
yes i could imagine that in addition to
a widespread interest in acetylcholine
uh there must be a huge interest in
develop well there is a huge interest in
developing
other biosensors for the biogenic amines
so that's quite exciting to hear
okay i think we are coming to the end
here unless
anybody in the audience wants to quickly
type in a question into the question or
answer box i'll give people maybe
20 or 30 seconds uh
and while we're waiting for that if our
um
fabulous presenters if there's anything
that you wanted to add
about your project or any sort of um
last minute things that you want to talk
about to get people to go to your
posters
you can also use those last few minutes
for that as well i'll open the floor
how are you expressing these nano
sensors
or how do you plan to express them
christine you may be you may be on mute
oh uh sorry i think you got cut off
could you uh repeat that last question
the question is how are you expressing
or how do you plan to express these nano
sensors
um i would like to ask a follow-up to
what they mean by express um
but i uh do do you know what they're
trying to
mean by that well i suppose you have
your your probe the chemical probe but
also the enzyme
for converting so how do you get all
these things in the right place
um to ensure that the enzyme is
successfully being attached onto the
probe
um so uh in many parts
it's kind of broken into a couple steps
we want to ensure that the contrast
agent
is on the probe and we make sure that
the control sensor is ph sensitive
in the ph environments from ph 6 to 8
and in regards to the enzyme
we measure the enzyme activity
after we you know conjugate it onto the
sensor
and we also um according to literature
we know that the
the acetylcholine catalyzing enzyme
decreases the ph
and so if there's a local decrease in
the ph of the presence of the
acetylcholine
that is one way of knowing that the
esterase
enzyme was attached on successfully in
terms of how we want to see it
expressed you know in the end we would
like to see it you know expressed in the
brain uh current
methods right now at least for us going
into in vivo we are injecting it
um into the brain uh using a very
invasive method but
the end goal is to inject it into
the blood the bloodstream like a regular
contrast agent
and hopefully it will cross the blood
brain barrier
well great well thank you very much um i
think that
draws our session to a conclusion i
would like to thank all of the
presenters here and congratulate you on
uh being selected to give these talks
i'd like to thank the audience
for um viewing these these talks and for
the questions that came
in and with this we will close uh the
session and i would just like
to remind everybody that you can uh view
these uh
exciting uh scientific presentations in
their poster sessions
and of course there's all the
information here on the site if you wish
to
continue the conversation with our
awardees offline
so with that on behalf of michelle and
myself
i really hope you have a great rest of
the meeting thank you again for being
here and we will uh see you in virtual
space again
or in person i hope thank you
missions thank you
thank you
you